vamos con nuestra segunda invitada del
día en Colombia a raíces de los acuerdos
de La Habana que dieron por finalizado
el conflicto con la antigua guerrilla de
las FARC se creó la unidad de búsqueda
de personas dadas por desaparecidas en
Colombia más de 100.000 ciudadanos
fueron reportados como desaparecidos en
el contexto de la guerra y la mayoría
Siguen sin aparecer a punto de finalizar
su periodo frente a este organismo está
en directo América de France 24 Luz
Marina Monzón Cifuentes ella es abogada
y experta en derechos humanos y
construcción de paz Muchísimas gracias
celos Marina por estar con nosotros
Muchísimas gracias Con mucho Gracias por
darnos la oportunidad de compartir lo
que ha sido esta tarea de búsqueda bueno
y de eso se trata este espacio
precisamente ustedes buscan a Víctimas
de reclutamiento ilícito buscan a
combatientes de todos los bandos esto
también hay que decirlo y también a
otros civiles que padecieron en medio de
los enfrentamientos Cuál es la situación
de Colombia respecto a otros países de
la región en materia de desaparecidos
bueno Colombia tiene lastimosamente un
lugar
muy prominente en términos de cifras de
desaparecidos y de población afectada
por la desaparición que también hay que
mencionar El secuestro Yo creo que el
secuestro es algo que fue una práctica
de Los de sobre todo los grupos
guerrilleros que llevó a la desaparición
de muchas personas comparativamente Este
es el país que tiene mayor número de
desapariciones no solamente en términos
numéricos sino también la extensión de
la población en Colombia y en el tiempo
una desapariciones que se han prolongado
a lo largo de cinco décadas Esta es una
situación que no ha ocurrido en ninguna
parte del continente estamos hablando
que hay desaparecidos en Chile en
Argentina en Guatemala
localizados durante el conflicto o
durante la dictadura pero no en una
extensión de tiempo como de cinco
décadas como en Colombia y eso porque lo
menciono Porque es importante Ver que
esto incide en lo que es las
oportunidades de búsqueda de las
personas desaparecidas y en lo que somos
como sociedad sin duda quisiera
preguntarle Cuántas personas han hallado
y cómo ha sido este proceso de
restitución de derechos para estas
identidades y para sus familias bueno
Nosotros hemos avanzado en la búsqueda
de los desaparecidos a través de dos
tesis o dos teorías uno que las personas
se encuentran vivas y en la medida en
que podamos definir que hay fuentes de
información que nos llevan a considerar
que efectivamente esta hipótesis es
fuerte pues hemos logrado llevar al
reencuentro de familias de 11 personas
que estaban reportadas como
desaparecidas pero que luego estaban era
estaban vivas y estaban en unas
condiciones
Pues de desconexión con la familia en
otro de la otra tesis es que las
personas pueden estar muertas y entonces
hemos abordado distintos tipos de
escenarios entre ellos los cementerios
las fosas en Campos abiertos e incluso
en expedientes forenses y allí hemos
logrado recuperar
pues más de 700 cuerpos en distintos
espacios como digo
746 cuerpos que hemos entregado al
instituto de Medicina legal de los
cuales hemos logrado con la información
que produce la investigación humanitaria
extrajudicial llegar a la de
identificación de 11 personas que bueno
11 cuerpo en realidad que fueron
entregados a sus familias un mal que
padece en países latinoamericanos como
Colombia Es la falta de presupuesto
cuando se trata de causas humanitarias
en medio de tantas otras emergencias que
se presentan pues en un país como este y
por eso Quiero preguntarle a usted
Cuánto cuesta encontrar identificar
restaurar a una persona a su familia sea
en vida o se haya fallecida en Colombia
me refiero al presupuesto y al uso de la
tecnología para que se pueda llevar a
cabo todo este proceso tan complejo y
pues además estamos hablando de cinco
décadas no bueno esa es una muy buena
pregunta por varias razones porque
Qué significa porque la pregunta detrás
de esto es Qué significa Buscar Porque
cuando uno pone la perspectiva en en
estas partes que estás mencionando
efectivamente son partes de un proceso
pero ahí hace falta una parte que es
esencial y es quizás la que más demanda
recursos y
e Innovación para poder hacer una
búsqueda reparadora la búsqueda de las
personas desaparecidas es una medida de
reparación bajo el derecho internacional
Entonces cuando tú estás haciendo una
búsqueda Y esa búsqueda debe reparar a
las víctimas esa reparación tiene que
darse garantizando la participación de
esas víctimas en ese proceso de búsqueda
Entonces nosotros estamos consolidando
eso no te puedo en este momento decir
cuánto vale Pero estos actos aislados
Pues claro si tú puedes tener unas
cifras de Cuánto vale un ADN de Cuánto
vale una exhumación Pero eso no podría
transmitirse de esa manera porque eso
descontextualizaría lo que sería el
proceso de búsqueda Nosotros hemos
avanzado justamente en hacer que este
proceso que efectivamente está soportado
en tecnologías y hemos logrado utilizar
las tecnologías para poder agilizar la
búsqueda es decir utilizar georadares y
utilizar unas escáners sobre la Tierra
que nos ayudan a no tener que explorar
todo el territorio o el terreno donde
tenemos que ir sino por una Pues con
unos análisis que hacen esta tecnología
poder concentrar mucho más los esfuerzos
donde puede haber indicios de que pueden
hallarse personas o estructuras de
personas entonces
efectivamente lo estamos aplicando pero
no te puedo decir en este momento Ojalá
lo podamos hacer Próximamente Cuánto
vale una búsqueda pero una búsqueda en
este sentido que te estoy diciendo que
involucre la investigación que involucre
la participación y todos estos otros
elementos mire Este es un tema muy
técnico por supuesto pero claro usted le
da este este otro aporte que es la
humanidad dentro de un proceso de paz
después de un conflicto con una
guerrilla en Colombia así que por esto
Quiero preguntarle más allá esta labor
tan importante que ustedes hacen por qué
Porque es tan indispensable para una
familia encontrar el destino o lo que
fue de su ser querido y más en un
contexto de guerra por la dignidad
te lo digo así por eso es tan importante
la participación porque cuando una
persona de un núcleo familiar de una
comunidad o incluso de un grupo humano
que se articula alrededor de un
propósito cualquiera que él sea de un
pueblo étnico por ejemplo cuando una
persona desaparece ese ese rol de esa
persona desaparece dentro de ese núcleo
y se afecta
la violación no es solamente contra la
persona desaparecida sino contra todo el
entorno humano que hay a su alrededor y
esto causa efectos no solamente en el
momento de la desaparición sino
posterior porque qué haces tú cuando
tienes un lazo de afecto de de humano
con una persona que desaparece Pues tú
la buscas para qué Para protegerla si es
que está en riesgo porque lo primero que
piensas es está en riesgo pero cuando tú
no tienes información sobre qué pasó con
esa persona muchas cosas pasan por tu
mente
luz lo han matado lo han torturado está
detenido en algún lugar lo mataron y lo
tiraron a un basurero y todo esto todo
esto causa dolor sufrimiento angustia
entonces encontrar a las personas
desaparecidas ser restituir la dignidad
de la persona que fue desaparecida y la
dignidad de estas personas que muchas
veces todo lo que te acabo de relatar lo
hacen en condiciones absolutamente
adversas adversas Qué significa que no
le creen que está que ese familiar está
desaparecido que le dicen que tal vez
quiso irse para hacer quién sabe qué que
entonces todas esas respuestas que
significan para quien está buscando
desprotección Entonces esto causa más y
más daño Entonces al cabo de 15 20 30
años que duran las búsquedas de estas
familias pues ese sufrimiento Se
incrementa entonces encontrar a la
persona desaparecida es dignificar a esa
persona que ha dedicado mucha parte de
esa búsqueda pero también la memoria y
la dignidad de la persona que fue
desaparecida pues Luz Marina Monzón
Cifuentes de la unidad de búsqueda de
personas dadas por desaparecidas gracias
a usted no solamente por entregarnos el
balance al final de su periodo y las
cifras que sin duda son muy importantes
sino por entregarnos este factor de la
humanidad alrededor de encontrar a
nuestros desaparecidos en Colombia
gracias a usted pues no yo creo que es
muy importante sentir que esta
construcción de paz pasa por
reconectarnos con la humanidad que
muchas veces el conflicto armado nos
llevó a no tener y creo que el que esta
entidad sea una entidad humanitaria
extrajudicial significa que tenemos que
poner al centro esa